welcome back to the voncast I'm Von
Miller I'm here in Las Vegas and I got
Mr Vegas with me today my guy
um one of one of my my best colleagues
in in the league man I've been following
his career man we got a very uh special
relationship and it's super cool to have
him on my show
um two-time Pro Bowl defensive end
um really way way more than that got my
guy Max Crosby here man appreciate you
my G thank you I appreciate you bro
always thanks for having me on bro
um let me take a moment to show my guy
Max some love man 37 and a half career
sacks the most defensive snaps of all
linemen since 2019 that's 3 65 snaps and
I think that is that is really one of
the most impressive stats that you have
because we all know like how you play
this game you play it full speed you
know you can do the spin and you can you
can bull rush you can long arm you can
do all everything under the sun when it
comes to pass rush but your effort on
the football field and you do that every
single play and not miss a game how do
you do it
uh honestly man I appreciate it it
really comes down to preparation and
mindset because
um you know it really starts in the off
season I start in January and we
finished you know in January so
um it's non-stop for me I give
everything I have into my nutrition my
recovery
um literally every single box I make
sure it's checked and some so yeah when
I go out on the field I'm not thinking
about you know if I'm in good enough
shape to keep going so I want to show
the coaches like my my thing when I came
in they were like yeah he's a pass
rusher he's going to come in be a third
down guy and I was like no like I'm an
every down guy and I wanted to prove
that every day so yeah every time I go
out there I don't want to come out the
field and uh yeah I've been you know
blessed enough to stay healthy and just
keep keep rolling well for sure you are
definitely a red dot guy when you cut
them to cut on the film and when I say
Red Dot guys I mean when you watch the
film like no matter if he's making a
play or not you have to put the Red Dot
on them I know it was a big play that uh
I probably
probably your
um most successful
QB pressure it wasn't even on the
quarterback it was on Myers at the end
of the game he's running down the field
30 yards putting pressure on the
receiver I don't know why the receiver
through the ball back but we we're
getting we get into that later we get
into that later but this guy man he
plays he plays with his hair on fireman
and to not miss a snap in um four whole
years is crazy man um Chandler Jones has
publicly said that you are the reason
why he came to the Raiders
um I you know if I had an opportunity I
would love to go to the Raiders too man
and play with Max Crosby but you also
have another guy there too Tyrique
Wilson what makes you guys the best Trio
or the best duo in the league
yeah you know there's there's a lot of
football that's got to be played you
know for us to establish ourselves as
you know the best Duos you know
obviously there's a ton of them you know
obviously Micah D law you and Greg
um Chris and Frank and Casey
um obviously Frank's in Denver now but
um you know what I think they got
Brandon Browning and Randy Gregory there
too they got a trio yeah they got some
guys Randy's one of my one of my closest
dudes he's a baller
um but honestly I really think
um we got a lot of work to do I feel
like the first year there's a lot of
growing pains ups and downs but
um Chandler Jones is you know him saying
you know I came to play with you know
Max Crosby is the biggest honor like I
was in college talking in interviews and
I would show him like this is from 2017
I'm like Chandler Jones one of my
favorite guys one of the most unorthodox
rushers and now we're teammates and he's
you know bragging about me which is
honestly surreal so yeah you know
Chandler's you know had an incredible
offseason I'm excited to have him you
know take another huge step this year
and Tyrese coming in uh getting healthy
and you know we you know I haven't seen
a play yet but from everything I've
heard and everything I've seen you know
as far as as tape you know he's he's a
special player so we're excited to get
him rolling man it's it's crazy like you
said they got uh you know a crazy Duos
and and and uh and trios around the
league you know Denver they have Frank
Clark uh Randy Gregory Brandon Browning
um you got Khalil Mack and Joey Bosa
with the Chargers you know Miami you got
Bradley Chubb and Jalen and you know
they stacked over there too they got
Malik they got Malik uh they got my guy
Malik over there as well yeah um but
some of the best Duos in sports
let's talk about we got to start I think
since we're in the NFL we got to start
with
we got to start with
we're probably Patrick Mahomes and
Travis Kelsey I was gonna say the same
thing they got to be number one right
now they got to be number one man I
think you know the splash Bros yeah or a
great Duo as well stuffing clay for sure
you got any other Duos there's a lot you
know I'm a little biased you know I've
been uh you know ever since Hardin went
to Houston I was uh you know I've been a
Hardin fan so him and Joelle are a
pretty good Duo but you know they
haven't haven't been able to come
through you know in the playoffs but you
know they're another dynamic duo for
sure there's a lot of them out there got
the Joker you got the Joker Joker in the
mall that's dangerous
my guys we got Josh Allen Stefan Diggs
Josh Allen Stefan Diggs there's
I think
low-key the sleeper one is Herbert and
uh Keenan Allen oh they've been chopping
up for the last three four years so
they'll both be healthy and they'd be
ready to go man you got Stafford and
Cooper cup as well Stafford and Cub yeah
they got a bowl together obviously you
know that
um there's there's a lot of them I think
honestly and I'm not even trying to say
the most
scary Duo and I remember the day when uh
you got traded to the Rams and when I'd
seen Von Miller Aaron Donald I'm like
this is not even fair bro and y'all did
exactly what y'all were supposed to do
bro and that that last Drive in the
Super Bowl
was crazy man but it's crazy you say
that man because we was looking up like
you know all of these things like all
these Duos before the show even started
and for you to bring it up man like me
and Aaron don't bro that is dope man my
God man come on that's that's uh two
Hall of Famers right there you can't
can't get any better man we was hearing
we we're here in Vegas um Aaron Donald
has came out here for my past first
summit and that's why I'm here this
weekend this is my seventh annual pass
first summit
um I started this uh password Summit
back in
oh it was 2000 and what I started seven
years ago I started several years ago
um Vic Beasley
um I had a position coach that was my
position coach for the Denver Broncos he
left and he was Vic Beasley's defensive
coordinator and he was telling me like
man you got to work out with this guy
work out with this guy and I finally got
on the page with with Vic and I told him
to come out to San Francisco I was like
come out of San Francisco man we could
work out I'll show you how I train we
can go over some film and do some d-line
work and Vic had told the reporters
um they're in Atlanta
and I was just searching my name one day
and it was like Ron Miller's having his
password Summit in California and I'm
like no I'm not but
I I might as well like ride on this uh
he's inviting all the passwords out this
is what they gonna do and you know I
started it then and um it was really
honestly when I started it I just I just
really wanted to be around all the best
guys in the league and I wanted to
continue to grow and I wanted others to
have an environment to continue to grow
as well and I talked to some of the guys
that I respected around the league like
JJ Watt and Justin Houston and I call a
lot of these guys and Khalil Mack and
everybody said they was on board and we
did it and it was it was a success and
um when you see the Von Miller pass for
a summer it it immediately screams like
a Von Miller coaching clinic but Max
you've been there it's nothing like that
we just it's really a place where iron
sharpens iron and we all get around each
other and we talk about our craft
because you got the quarterback counts
you got receiver counts but this is a
place where all the young Sac artists
that's running up the sacks and all the
ogs and everybody in between coaches and
everybody can come and talk past rush
and um this is my seventh year doing it
Max has been huge at that man what do
you like about the past first summer
yeah I think you're you're spot on with
it you know it's my third year
um and honestly the craziest part about
it you know they you mentioned like you
would think you know Von Miller is gonna
you're just going to be coaching
everybody but you know when I first
started getting into pass rush I you
know I didn't start playing DN until my
senior year and one of you know one of
my coaches told me he's like every
rusher is different you can't and you
were one of the names that were
mentioned like you probably can't do
what Von Miller can do and certain guys
can't do what I can do and you know I
can't do what Chandler Jones does but if
you can get one or two things from those
guys
um and apply it to your game you know
you can steal an extra two three four
sacks every year and uh you know just
being around the guys last year like
being around d-wear who's you know you
know him more than me he's an absolute
Legend and like guys like you know Cam
Jordan and Justin Houston like people
you know Justin Houston has 100 what 20
almost 120 sacks now he's crazy he's
crazy and he's still balling he's got he
had another double digit sack here so
just having a guy like that in the room
talking to a lot of younger guys and
like for me last year like me being able
to you know pick his brain with Chandler
it was incredible so yeah and and it's
just a testament man it builds that that
that Foundation that you want in the
league uh you know we don't have to say
exactly what game it was or whatever but
you I remember you calling me last year
before the game you're like yo yeah
you're doing this and this what do I
need to do just to be able to create
those relationships just to be in the
environment where you can talk to those
guys and create those relationships man
no that's what it's all about bro I
remember you calling me on the plane
you're like bro I was thinking about you
and I was rushing I'm telling you it's
like it worked and I was going nuts
watching the whole game it was dope man
and that's that's what it's really all
about it was dope man and I and I
another thing that influenced me to like
create an environment like this I was on
tour in 2017 with Drake and Drake had
all like these young like upcoming Like
Rappers and he had the older guys and he
would always be around these guys like
he can ring it up on his own but he
stayed like in the mix and stayed on the
sound and stay on the wave to help
improve him and everybody else around
him man and it takes a special person to
really like put themselves in there and
create like these moments man and do
that man and we're here at we're here at
um
the seventh annual pass for someone we
got ideas me and Max we got ideas to
make it even better than what it is man
y'all stay tuned for that man it's gonna
be super dope man but our job is to stop
the quarterback
um let's you you play you play Pat
Mahomes twice a year I used to play them
twice a year now I'm just playing them
once a year
get a fans you know our idea how how
tough it is to stop Patrick Mahomes and
what it's like to play in your special
homes because the guy for me was Tom
Brady I always play Tom Brady each and
every year but now it's it's you know
the Raiders the Chiefs you going against
Pat Mahomes like how is it going against
Patrick Holmes twice a year and what's
it like Russia [__] yeah honestly uh
you know when you watch him you see the
arm Talent you see the crazy you know
left-hand throws when he's falling like
you see all that you see the ability and
you know the athleticism to get away
from you know Defenders but I think the
one thing that people don't talk about
enough is just his competitive nature
like that dude is one of the most
competitive people I've ever played
against you know when I'm out there he's
talking talking [__] right back at me
and I'm coming he like doesn't most
quarterbacks aren't like that you know
they're silent they're not going to say
much like Pat's one of those guys that
he's going to get right back in your
face and be like yo like let's go then
what's up it's crazy because we I don't
know if we we got a clip of uh I'll pull
that up yeah what was that what had
happened like y'all you had hair but it
Patty I got into a little what what had
happened yeah we were playing in KC and
uh the environment was crazy it was
Monday Night Football and uh you know we
were going back and forth I got him with
a sack on the first drive and ended up
getting them a second time and I'm
talking like I'm I'm naturally you know
I'm always barking at everybody now I
just just kind of that's just part of my
nature and uh Pat wasn't going for it
you know he was talking back and he's
like all right what's up and so they
went down and scored and I'm standing
I'm watching them in the end zone and
Pat was running with a guy or I think
his Kelsey scored and they were all
running around the end zone and I get
bumped behind my back I get hit with his
shoulder I'm like and I turned and it
was Pat and he was still running and I'm
like oh no I'm not going for that so I
ran straight to him and I head butted
them like what's up so we were just John
and you know everybody online obviously
made a big deal of it but after every
single time we play he's the first guy
that comes up to me and we always show
love so I got a bunch of respect for him
and you know it's an honor you know I
can chase him down all the time man I
got huge respect for Patrick Mahomes man
it's a lot of guys out there man it's a
lot of you know tough quarterbacks to
tackle man
um who was the hardest quarterback to
tackle that's tough um Lamar is crazy
bro I was gonna say Lamar's you're
playing him at the beginning of the
season when I played against tomorrow
last year and I had uh two sacks in a
game I had one second that game my
second sack like I had him and he just
kind of like ran it down and jumped out
of life I had him on his shoulder and he
like kind of jumped out I was like bro
this is crazy bro who's the hardest
quarterback for you to for you to give
honestly you know there's a lot of I
feel like yeah obviously you got to put
Lamar in that conversation Mr Wilson
Russell Wilson is right when I played
Russell he was when he was with the
Seattle Seahawks nobody wanted to play
Russell Wilson he would run around they
run around again run around find an open
guy and like and like hit him bro like
Russell Wilson Kyla Mary yeah Kyle Kyler
broke out of one of my socks I don't
know how I had him by like two shoulders
literally grab both his shoulder pads
and he like squatted and slid out and
made a play and I was sick but yeah I
think Kyler is tough and I think Josh
Allen he was my first career at College
side it was a half side but I still
counted and he was at Wyoming and that
dude like dragged me for three yards I'm
like okay this dude's a monster and then
I got I sacked him one time like I think
it was my second year in the league but
he's like tackling another DN like the
dude is enormous and athletic so yeah
he's another guy stuff I will say this
about Josh Allen every time that I've
played Josh Allen
I have got a sack on Josh Allen and the
Buffalo Bills that includes the games
and practice
the games and practicing I would have to
say every time that I play against Josh
Allen
um you know I get a sack but it's it's
crazy how we transition from you know
the old quarterbacks the old the the old
goats like Tom Brady and Peyton Manning
to a newer younger generation of like
Patrick Mahomes and Josh Allen and all
these guys man speaking of the goats you
know Brady is now like a minority owner
in the Raiders yeah
um what are the odds that he comes out
and throws a pass out there do y'all see
him around like have you had any
conversations with Brady at the facility
I have I have it was a couple weeks ago
um and it was super casual and random
but I was not expecting to see Tom Brady
on that day it was like a Wednesday or
something and he walked in and uh he was
awesome but yeah the possibility I'm
honestly you know obviously we got Jimmy
G he's coming back he's gonna be healthy
but
um you know you never know what's going
to happen Tom Brady's competitor the
greatest of all time so
um you know at the absolute worst you
know if everything doesn't go the way
it's supposed to and we need them I
would not be surprised if Tom Brady
shows up in the Raider Jersey oh man
it's already ready man I love Tom Brady
like yeah I even contemplated like you
know you know in a tattoo shop you start
thinking about like tattoos to get like
it was a 12 popped up in my mind 18
popped up in my mind too you know I love
Peyton Manning and I love Tom Brady but
you know Tom Brady is just so cool man I
remember I came to a practice
um
I came to UCLA and I ran into Tom
Brady's like in the off season he saw me
he was like fun he was like happy and
that grunk was right there bro and I was
like bro but the only reason
that you could dislike Tom Brady is
because he wins you know what I'm saying
100 because he wins without you that's
the only reason to dislike Tom Brady
other than that like he gets he's like a
creative player on and off the football
field man I love Tom Brady all the way
there's a lot of guys saying since you
know Tom Brady is you know part owner of
the Raiders they calling the the Raiders
Patriots West now y'all got a lot of
former like Patriots over there from
Jimmy G Josh McDaniels Chandler Jones
um the gym you know Dave Dave Zeigler
Jacoby Myers Jacoby Myers he love y'all
yeah he love the Raiders
he didn't complete it he's gonna play
the touchdown passes before he
he's now on the coaching staff and now
Brady in the ownership do you think
these guys have brought that winning
that that winning Patriot culture to the
Raiders yeah I think they have you know
it's different a lot of people talk
about the Patriot Way and how it you
know how it is but you know I think
having a mixture of you know obviously
they're bringing what they brought from
Bill Belichick in New England but the
Raiders history is is super deep and
like this last week we had all the
Raider Legends you know freaking Charles
Woodson Ted Hendricks all the Legends
come in and they got to be with our
coaches and uh it was just awesome to
see and see everybody you know kind of
getting on the same page because the
Raiders will never change you know the
Raiders are always going to be the
Raiders and be the bad boys of the
league and that's what we're trying to
bring back but at the same time you know
New England brings winning as well and
and the Raiders have won a lot in the
past so if we bring both of that you
know both of those cultures together I'm
bringing the right guys I think you know
we're going to do a lot of great things
man I got Jimmy G I'm a huge fan of
Jimmy G Devante Devonte Adams
um bro y'all loaded man I'm excited man
you know there's a lot of talk about
like all the Raiders need is is a
quarterback they can throw the Devonte
and yeah I got it now yeah yeah I got it
now y'all y'all load it now um from a
defensive ends point of view
what makes Jimmy G Elite quarterback
I think what Jimmy you know ever since
he's got in the league
he's always you know been the guy that
you know first off he was the guy behind
Brady so they're like all right he's
going to be the predecessor to Brady and
he always kind of got the short end of
the stick I feel like and it's almost
impossible Tom Brady's in front of you
you know there's he's won seven Super
Bowls it's almost unfair but you know
what he brings is just that dog
mentality you know ever since he's been
in there you know he you know obviously
all the reports come out and people are
talking about you know his injuries and
things like that I see that dude in the
building every day it's I'm in the hot
tub and he's in there getting rehab and
he's working and he's already on the
field doing what he's doing and like
um I just feel like he's a winner and
and that's proven he's won a lot more
than he's lost since he's been in the
league no matter where he's been so I'm
fired up for him you know I've been
around him a ton and he's just a he
brings a great energy to the to the
locker room and and the guys are already
loving him so we're just fired up to get
him out there and training camping and
fire off man you know I like to put my
GM hat on sometimes man like that that
Jimmy G pick up was perfect
um and him Devonte Adams
um
Josh Jacobs crazy running back offensive
line has gotten better of course the
defense is Stout
um you're in perfect position man all
you really got to do is beat the Chiefs
one time we gotta beat him up be the
Chiefs at least one time
at least one time then that's the
pathway in man in the AFC West I played
there for 10 and a half years so
it is it is when I was when I was there
when the charges was going crazy and you
know the Raiders are going crazy they
built up the offensive line and you got
Patrick but it was the toughest division
in all the sports man so I know how
tough the AFC West is man
um they got talent all over man on each
and every team the Raiders are stacked
stacked with guys like Max Crosby and
we've done our research on Max Crosby
and we've heard that on your iPhone lock
screen you like to put your gold
reminders in 2021
you had a hundred plus emoji for a
hundred
QB pressures and 100 M's and then you
had and then in 2022 you had a picture
of the deep the defensive player to your
trophy on your screen it's 2023. we're
here at the the password Summit in Vegas
what is on your lock screen now can you
can you show us what you what you got
she's got my phone right there
um
we don't have to share this for the
world but you can look at it and then
we'll talk about it uh after but yeah I
look at that every single day so that's
hard that's that's the goal um there's a
lot more to it you know there's a lot of
a lot of deep meanings uh multiple
meanings but yeah that's my goal man is
be the best I'm sorry and I'm a huge
believer of being able to see your goals
man constantly reminded of your goals in
life man and really commend everything
that that you have into winning games
man and for um this Raiders season
coming up what are your goals for the
team this season
number one is
get in the playoffs first you know
easiest way the easiest way to get to
the playoffs is to win the division yeah
win the division that's obviously
running through the Chiefs so um we know
what that what that comes with
um they're a great team but yeah we have
a ton of goals I don't want to make any
predictions anything like that but
um I feel like if guys keep showing up
the way they're showing up in OTA as we
have the whole entire team there Devonte
Adams it's Devonte Adams you know he
could be wherever he wants to be that
dude is there every single day myself
Chandler Jones everybody's in the
building trying to get this thing right
and uh that's that's the first step so I
feel like everybody's doing their part
um and we just got to keep going and
ride that momentum and uh yeah you know
the first step is just getting in the
playoffs and you know go from there we
um I know we talked a little bit about
about Tyree Wilson Early in the show but
the Raiders took him at the number
seventh pick and you know I love to put
my GM hat on
yeah I got the number seven pick y'all
got a loaded team
um
and y'all go and get a defensive end
Tyree Wilson and what that tells me is
this guy is ready to play this guy is
the real deal I know you haven't seen
him practicing but I know you can get a
lot just by you know talking to a guy
how does his mom say what do you like
about Tyree so far yeah you know he's a
quiet kid um he's he's got all the
ability in the world to do this I think
six five two seventy five he's a huge
frame a great athlete and it really
comes down to putting in the work and I
and I see him doing that he's doing that
every day
um you know as a rookie there's a lot of
things going on you know he's got you
know you're a top 10 pick you got all
the media stuff all this going on but
he's been focused and uh that's that's
the main thing that I take away from him
you know he's locked in he wants to get
back out on the field with us
um he's been awesome since he's been
there you know the first day we got
there you know we got a text from you
know our d-line coach saying you know
the rookies are asking what y'all want
you know in the d-line room and you know
how it is like that's something small
but it's important and uh they they
showed up and stacked the whole d-line
room with snacks and everything so yeah
they're doing all the right things and
obviously you know Byron young as well
from Alabama uh Nesta
um Adam plant Jr we got a bunch of guys
you know on the d-line six new you know
rookies coming in China Junior that's my
dog man
grow up since he was in junior high
school man I didn't know he's with the
Raiders yeah he's with the Raiders man
his dad is a is a great dude yeah shout
out to Big Plant big plan okay
now we're Departed the show where we
have got to talk about one of the best
highlights of last season okay the
Chandler Jones farmer recovery to Matt
Jones from then the max Jones stiff arm
and the walk-off touchdown ice listen I
don't like swearing on stuff and but I
tell you like I swear when I saw this
play
and I saw him throw the ball back and I
saw Chandler Jones catch the bro I stood
up and I screamed I I literally stood up
and I screamed and I yelled and then he
sniffed on Mac Jones and I yelled even
louder and like bro I like I like I'm
getting Goosebumps talking about like I
know you see it bro I'm getting Goose
I'm getting Goosebumps talking about it
as a defensive end yeah and then that's
our boy too that's the boy that's our
boy two that's your team man it's your
dog that's that's my boy I've been doing
Chandler I'm watching this in Buffalo
and I see them do this like what was
your reaction when you seen that I
honestly I couldn't believe I couldn't
believe that actually happened for the
game for the game and I knew it was the
last play of the game so
I knew it was a tie ball game I was not
expecting you know I'm expecting them to
run the ball
that's where my mind was at so when I
seen uh ramandre he like he threw it
back to Jacoby and I'm like what's going
on and so I just I really ran at Jacoby
and cracked him a little bit later
this is the pressure but I thought I was
I was kind of scared low-key
see in the moment I was like I can't I
can't be the one that messed that up
because it was insane the place was so
loud it was I'll never forget it
literally forever man yeah I had some
crazy endings That season like y'all
beat Denver crazy y'all be Denver in the
crazy like ending as well
is that the craziest ending that you've
ever been a part of 100
especially on that stage at home at home
we needed a win as McDaniels versus
Belichick you know he wanted to get that
dub badly and the way it happened it
couldn't couldn't have been any better
man that's that's amazing bro like and
then it hit even harder because like
that's our dog like that's the boy
that's a dog and I saw hit like stiff
arm and then him run like I couldn't
believe it oh like I couldn't believe
when he's stiff on them I'm like he
looked like a running back out there it
was it was different shout out Chandler
bro that's my dog man I love Chandler
man it just hits even harder when it's
your boy that you noticed oh my God look
at this
oh my God it just hits anymore I've been
a part of some crazy endings man like
you know Tim Tebow to the marriage
Thomas in the playoffs to send it to him
to send it over
um I've been in a part of some crazy
endings man and you know that was that
was a crazy one man shout out Chandler
Jones man for making it happen man
um uh really is Jacoby
big shout out I love it
hey everything happens for a reason so
100 you got here and now you you never
know you know the race going deep you
know you never know amen also last
season you signed a 100 million dollars
extension
on the second anniversary anniversary of
your suburb your sobriety
um we know you you got the you got a
tattoo on your hand and it's a we know
it's a very special day for you man
um talk about what that meant to you man
like yeah it's honestly wild
um I remember the night before I got the
call you know how it is getting that
your first big extension
um the whole week was hectic you know
we're going back and forth with the team
and my agents I'm on the phone 24 7 and
the night before you know I got uh I got
the call like listen
we're at the right spot you know we we
got everything where I was comfortable
they're comfortable and uh it was crazy
man I was going in the next day at six
a.m workout like usual um and I just
posted this picture but I already knew
that deal you know the deal was done and
it was going to be announced
um but it's just crazy how it works man
that's how God works you know in
mysterious ways and I feel like
everything happens for a reason so it
means the world man and now I'm over
three years sober
um and it's been an incredible journey
so far so it's an everyday process but
you know things like that just shows
like the everyday work is is paying off
and you know that's what it's all about
man you weren't hardly you weren't
highly recruited out of um
um out of high school um you had one
offer from Eastern Michigan you know I
came to your wedding and you like you
and your wife you've been through all
type of stuff to to get to this moment
man um does this success
um mean more after after having to prove
yourself and then what's next what's
what is Max Crosby you know do next
yeah you know I think you know
everybody's got their own story you know
I feel like I've always had the chip on
my shoulder I feel like I always had to
go above and beyond to prove my worth
um but that's what I appreciate about it
because I love when people are doubting
me I I live for it and I keep notes on
everything like even reporters and don't
even try to be Petty but like server
reporters will say certain things I'll
screenshot it and I got a whole Vault
that's the energy to all the things but
that's that's what I I need and and to
get going on a daily basis and
um you know it just makes it even more
special because I've I've been talking
about this moment since I was at Easter
and I was 230 pounds skinny skinny uh DN
and I always talked about it and I
always worked for it and I constantly
and put in the work to get better and
I'm doing more and more today even
though I got the money and I'm good and
all that but I have so much more to
prove and my legacy is everything you
know I want to win
um you know going into your next
question I that's the number one thing I
want to win a Super Bowl and I want to
be in Hall of Fame uh no matter what
that looks like I'm Gonna Keep My work
until I get that and I'm on a mission
man I do it every single day and I'm you
know just you know I'm 25 years old I've
been through a lot but I appreciate all
the scars that come along because that's
what made me you know who I am today and
I got kids I got kids with an S you got
a beautiful daughter man
um I already know the answer to this
question man does it mean even more
after having your daughter one thousand
percent man uh you know how it is you
know you were sending me your kids
um you know their baby pictures uh and
that you know when I was When Rachel was
pregnant going you know if we're getting
ready for the baby I'm like talking to
you and talking to guys that have gone
through and talking to guys in the
locker room like I'm I have no idea how
to be a dad I've never you know it's new
to me but that's what it's all about at
the end of the day like this is when you
talk about the past for some and things
like that it really comes down to just
that Bond because it's more than
football at the end of the day you know
we're going to be friends for life and
you know just having having guys like
you in my corner and asking for advice
from a dude like Cam Jordan and dudes
that have really gone through it
um it's incredible man so yeah it means
it means the world she's growing up uh
faster and faster every single day she's
pulling herself up on the couch crawling
she's saying dada now so life is good
man I can't complain that's dope man um
max probably Max Max Crosby he
definitely got that bag you know we they
they want to ask us what was the first
thing that you bought when you got that
bad first thing I bought when I got the
bag
um
I don't do you remember I'm trying to
think
um
honestly I don't remember I don't it
wasn't like one huge purchase of the
gate um
I knew what I wanted I wanted the
Rolls-Royce Wraith the silver and black
Batmobile I'm end up getting that a few
months after but
um you know I looked out I had some
things with the family I wanted to get
done and I got that done so that was
super important to me
um but yeah I think the first like big
purchase was uh yeah The Wraith for sure
you know you like you said man you know
when I think about my first big
purchases you know you take care of the
family you do some things I feel like
you know the purchase that really stands
out for me
um I just went to the Camaro dealership
and I just bought a Camaro like this is
back when I got my rookie deal like you
know after my your Ricky dude and you're
going to your second deal like you know
you grown and stuff now but yeah when I
got my first when I got my first deal
like I just went to the Camaros I went
to Camaro uh dealership and I bought a
Camaro with just my ID like I went in
there and I talked to this guy I got
this guy on the phone did that send us
here seeing that there I went there
without a Camaro and just my ID and I
left with a Camaro and just my ID I love
that so that that was like my first
purchase of course you get older and you
realize you know certain stuff don't
really matter and more stuff does matter
and you start having kids and you know
now I said it's totally different but
for me that's that's that's one thing
that that stands out for me um you're
back you're a big tattoo guy big tattoo
guy and so am I yes I love tattoos man I
actually got one big tattoo all over my
mom when I first started getting tattoos
I got my first tattoo with my mom and
she said I'm gonna let you get tattoos
just just make me one promise she said
don't get your hands neck or face
and so me my brain instantly went to
okay if I can't get those then
I'm gonna do everything else so I went
in I wouldn't I literally I still got
the bottom of my feet to go and like my
armpits and I just got like a little
space on my back like in certain areas
and I got my my probably it's probably
too much information but then I got my
left butt cheek and I just gotta I just
gotta get that but other than that like
I got all I got everything man
um you were a big tattoo guy man you
even have the Raiders Shield tattooed on
your arm yeah yeah what do you like
about tattoos man like don't they hurt
like any painful like yeah they're
definitely painful you know it doesn't
get any easier anytime you get tattoos
um I'll tell you and the older you get
I already know man but yeah I love
tattoos I literally I was 17 I took my
brother's ID and I went into the place
and I got uh Crosby and the date I was
born on my wrist because I just wanted a
tattoo
um and then I went from there I got my
grandmother on there and then I just
started going crazy
um so yeah I've always loved tattoos and
I definitely I got a lot of work to do
for sure what's your favorite tattoo
my favorite tattoo
um
obviously probably my neck I got the
triangle I got triangles everywhere but
I got times everywhere too man yeah you
got the the V yeah you got on the back I
already know but yeah I got you know the
triangle that symbolizes a lot obviously
number one my my sobriety so uh I put
that everywhere I stamp it I got on my
face mask now so yeah man it's
everywhere and I just it's different you
know it was a probably the worst most
painful tattoo yeah the neck in the back
of the neck but they're my favorite so
yeah um did you get any new ones this
off season
I got an appointment uh in about a month
and I'm about to get my whole chest
torso top my back yeah about to yeah
yeah I got some new tattoos this off
season two I had um when it got my my
boy Damaris Thomas tattooed on my back I
got a Dirk Nowinski my favorite
basketball player I'm from Dallas Legend
yeah so Dirk and the fade away I got him
fading away on my back I got my son
tatted on there and my Uncle June bug he
had passed away I put him on there
um start rocking the triple V's
um I put that on my back as well and you
know I did that I did all that this off
season
um let's talk about your name though you
know before the show I was talking
before the show I wasn't even thinking
right because I had this I had this
little fun fact uh Max with two x's and
I was asking you about kids and I was
like man if you have another if you have
another boy are you gonna put a third X
on there and he's like no no no okay
okay I have Max XXX but the story behind
your name Max with two x's where did
that come from
yeah so you know the story is out
already but it comes from uh my mom you
know I was almost 12 pounds of birth so
she threw another X on there called me
you know double X so I was a huge baby
they literally had to break my
collarbone to get me out I was like
stuck so
um I put her through hell but
um yeah you know she got she got the two
x's and I love it because it's Unique
and you know I feel like it fits me if
you're sorry I mean before we get to the
fan questions right here I got one more
question for you
um they call you Max the Condor do you
remember the first time that you heard
that name yeah I heard it my rookie year
week four we're playing the Colts and
that was the first time I really got
real reps in a game you know I was
getting like 15 20 before that I was
struggling and then I had like my
Breakout game and I've been starting
sunshine and uh Brian baldinger big
shout out to Baldi he's the man yeah
Audi's breakdown quality breakdowns and
that's where it came from you know he
made a breakdown on Twitter and he was
like man this guy's got super long arms
you know it looks like a condor out
there flying around and blah blah blah
and it stuck you know and now all the
fans and all them call me that so I love
it you know I I got I feel like I have
10 different nicknames but I just you
know I roll with all of them for sure
that's all right shout out body man what
about for me man if I had if you could
give me a nickname would you give me
go
I mean first ballot no like a nickname
like right
goat I mean that's yeah
I mean as simple as that was that the
craziest nickname I wouldn't say it's
crazy but the nickname that I have that
everybody from like Denver Broncos team
coming they call me Fam because when we
first got a key to leave TJ Ward and
like everybody there like anybody I mean
I was like what's up fam you know we
were like found filming that like you
know I was just trying I'm a team guy
like so I was like fan fan fam and then
Lee he just started calling me Fam he's
like man we're gonna go over the fam
house like Hey we're family like
whenever you say fam everybody just
everybody always knew it was me so you
know shout out my God Super Bowl team
man shout out lead man fam the fam
nickname it it kind of you know it kind
of
it kind of evaporated now because I'm
I've been on two other teams since then
but you know now they just call me V and
I just call me Von you know five eight
forty four oh you know I I like those
names we got we got a fan question right
here from James mcinley Max you're super
swagged out always give us some tips on
the drip
honestly I just try to
be different uh my mom you know I get
that from my mom you know she always so
I was a kid don't fit in you know don't
be the guy that wants to fit in and
follow like always do you
um and so
I express that in every way like I like
jewelry I like nice clothes I like
different color cars different that's
just like my personality so yeah my tips
you know it doesn't even matter the cost
like you could put on something that's
30 bucks and make it right you know so I
just like being different and uh
expressing myself with tattoos jewelry
all that stuff I just want to show
everybody who I am yeah you're doing it
man you so it makes Crosby man there's
only one we got Luke Campbell when
you're a rookie who was the one
lineman that gave you that Ricky lesson
about the NFL whoa what the lesson I
know I got one you got a lesson I got
one and it was my first practice Trent
Brown he had just become the highest
paid online of all time these are demons
he was six eight three eighty at the
time the best shave of his life and I'd
go up and and practice and dudes didn't
want to go against him so I'm like I'll
go whatever so I'm trying to prove
myself this dude is a monster and he was
locking me up on a daily basis but I
finally beat him with like a long arm
and team and I got a sack and that took
my confidence to a whole nother level
yeah and uh yeah and and me and him you
know we're so cool to this day because I
was trying to kill him you know trying
to beat him in any way and he was just
locking me up I'm like this is not okay
but um he gave me that confidence you
know once I beat him and uh you know
that's that's what the league's All
About Trent Trent Brown is actually one
of my favorite officers along with Trent
Brown and Trent Williams you know both
is both Texas boys both of those guys
are two of my favorite offensive linemen
in the league and they're two of the
best offensive lineman in the league as
well but we have a fan question he said
who is the best or favorite offensive
lineman that you faced
oh that's tough
um
honestly I feel like
the most like back and forth most like
intricate battle I've had was two years
ago I got to play against Lane Johnson
in Vegas
um and we both are getting the best of
each other
um he's obviously you know when it comes
to right tackles he's that's you know
the best in the league so I was super
you know looking forward to that that
opportunity and uh me and him had a
battle um going back and forth and you
know to this day you know we're really
cool we swap jerseys and
um just being able to go against the
best and you know have that back and
forth battle you know it's like being in
a boxing ring and you know the guy
across from you is a dog and it's going
to be a fight and uh you know it was one
of those and you know we both gained a
lot of respect for each other on that
day those are the best man like when you
play against the best offensive lineman
and you have success because obviously
you just go to the other side and stay
over there
um but I always like to because I play
on left side so I always like to go over
to the right side and play you know the
left tackle just to show like man you
know I don't like to run from nobody man
and Lane Johnson is definitely
if not the best offensive lineman League
he's one of the best offensive alignment
and Lee I got a lot of respect for Lane
as well one more fan question for this
week's Von cast here in Las Vegas and
they say this one is for me and Max Max
and myself
what do you what did you think when you
saw Josh Allen was on the cover of the
new Madden
do I believe in the Madden Curse
um
I thought it was dope I thought it was
uh it was well deserved like Josh Allen
is is one of the most influential
um athletes in all of the world let
alone like quarterbacks in the NFL so
we're talking about Madden the the our
of Our Generation like this is the cover
that you want to be on and we got Josh
Allen on there I'm super excited I'm
super happy for that guy
um Josh Allen is one of the dopest human
beings in the world like if you gotta if
you got a son he having a birthday party
like you could have six people there and
let me tell you Josh Allen is going to
be one of those people he might not stay
there for the whole shebang but Josh
Allen is going to be there man Josh
Allen is great man for him to get on
that that cover man was super dope and
do we believe in the man curse I think
Patrick Mahomes kind of put that to risk
man I think I think I think Patrick
Mahomes played that to rest man but what
do you think about Josh Allen being on
the man cover like you said man he
deserves it and it's uh it's honestly
awesome you know he's a guy that you
know he came in I think a year before me
but
um seeing him come from Wyoming his low
recruited guy I got to play him twice in
college and just being able to see his
journey has been incredible and uh you
know a guy like me coming from a small
school there's not a ton of us out there
you know especially playing it you know
the level we're playing at you know he's
an All-Pro guy he's earned it and he
does it on a daily basis and you know
him better than me but every time I've
been around him he's been awesome man he
acts like you you would never know
that's the you know one of the best
quarterbacks in the world so I got a ton
of respect for him he's a great player
and we we play all this year so I'm
looking forward to it man and uh I'm
happy for Josh man he's earned
everything he's got and we happy for
Josh man we are happy for Max Crosby
um thank you for coming on my show man
it's an honored privilege to have you
here man if you ever need me for
anything man you already you already
know this man I'm a Texan way man got to
know you even more like coming to your
wedding and get to see get to meet your
brother and your family and your
beautiful wife and daughter man and it's
always dope when when the good guys win
man I'm happy for you man continue
success I'm gonna always be a fan I'm
gonna always be a be your brother man if
you ever need me you know I got you and
that could be anything man all love and
respect man I appreciate you Max Crosby
appreciate it appreciate you mike always
bro yes sir
[Music]
foreign